salut aujourd'hui je vous donne une
énigme oh quelle surprise benoît pas une
surprise puisque durant 32 jours je vous
donne une énigme tous les jours c'est
notre petit jeu à nous de l'été et avant
de vous donner l'énigme je vous donne la
solution de la vidéo d'hier si vous
l'avez pas vu commencer par regarder la
vidéo d'hier puisque là je vais donner
la solution la solution c'est que le
fils à trois ans et le père 33 ans
c'est comme ça qu'ils cumulent pour
faire 36 spontanément vous avez
forcément pensé à 30 ans et 6 ans qui ne
fonctionnait pas par rapport à ce que je
disais dans l'énigme non c'est 33 et 3
il fallait voir le calcul d'une manière
un peu différente pour le trouver je
pense que vous avez été très nombreux à
trouver je regarderai le quota de pouce
en l'air pour voir le nombre de bonnes
réponses et c'est l'énigme en a fait
penser à une autre que je vous donne
aujourd'hui énigmes 26 l'énigme d'hier
l'a25 elle m'a fait penser à celle ci
qui est hyper intéressante en fait quel
nombre dans tout l'univers du
mathématiques ne s'est pas de
mathématiques complexes des
mathématiques normal
quel est le nombre quiconque divise par
lui-même donne comme résultat
son double ça paraît impossible comme ça
en même temps ce ne serait pas une
énigme mais c'est tout à fait réalisable
je vous laisse réfléchir à ça si vous
trouvez la réponse mais tu es un pouce
en l'air qu'on voit le nombre de bonnes
réponses par rapport au nombre de vues
mais ne mettez pas la réponse dans les
commentaires pour laisser les autres
cherchent et profitez encore du soleil
et profitez-en aussi pour vous abonner à
la chaîne avant de partir car le mortal
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
oui